well joining us now is the party's
former Westminster leader Ian Blackford
Heights good to see you thanks very much
for joining us on the program will you
be a good leader he will be and he's
he's a guy that I think has got an awful
lot of very positive treats as his
personality is a very engaging character
he's someone that cares very deeply
about people I think you can see that in
his past and someone that's actually got
tremendous empathy but Above All Else he
is a tremendous team person so he will
govern in a different way from Nicola
we're moving on to a new generation the
first Scott's Asian to become her first
Minister someone that's only in his 30s
I think people are going to be very
pozily surprised by what Hamza does as
our leader
um he's not done a great job in health
though has he I mean there's all sorts
of issues as far as the health
department is concerned and he was in
charge of that previously yeah but look
I think at the end of the day every
Health Service right across the United
Kingdom has really struggled in the
post-pandemic period it's gotten worse
than most well look at the end of the
day he's managed to get through the
negotiations with the health unions
without losing a single day to strike
action he's reached agreement with the
health unions yes of course there is a
backlog that needs to be dealt with we
need to get the numbers down but over
the course of the last few months that's
been happening we still have a Health
Service when people need it when it
comes to acute care does really quite a
remarkable job and I think people are
going to see that he will be very much
focused on delivery whether it's a
Health Service or whether it's elsewhere
and people should judge them that's what
he does as first Minister over the
course of the coming months what should
the first Minister's first job be I
think what the first Minister has to do
is show that they can bring the party
together after this election contest
he'll do that I'm pretty divided it will
be a big test 52-48 I mean yeah look
they're much closer than that no that is
a close result but I think what he will
demonstrate that the party has been
right to give them the authority to lead
he will have a big tent he's talked
about that he needs to make sure that
the Scottish government is focused on
delivery we need to show that we're
worthy of the trust of the people of
this country and of course then we need
to move on from that we've got a general
election coming down the road in a year
18 months and or so and he needs to make
sure that he leads and re-energizes the
the independence campaign that we have a
discussion about what kind of country
that Scotland should become I know these
are challenges that that Hamza is very
much ready to to lead on Not Elected by
the people of course should he have a
snap election some suggesting that would
be a good way to unite the party again
well I think one of the things that will
happen today of course is that every MSP
is going to have a voters who they want
to elect as their their first Minister
we've got a UK general election coming
down the road so people will have 15
months it could be 18 months away but
people will have their say uh on the SNP
and Hamza Yusuf at that point but also
let's remember the two labor first
ministers were elected in a similar
fashion this is not unusual for a way
for things to be done of course he's
standing on the SNP Manifesto that every
MSP stood on in 2021 there's a mandate
from the electorate there he will get on
and do the job make sure that we're
dealing with the cost of living crisis
make sure that we're giving proper
leadership to people there's a
tremendous job to do to show that we can
grow the economy in Scotland I'll
certainly be working with them on that
and my role as his business ambassador
to show that there's a bright future for
Scotland you know we've got a fantastic
opportunity with green energy to create
a new Industrial Revolution if you like
a green Industrial Revolution I think
people are going to be very surprised
positively surprised by what harms are
bringing to this role
um do you think he will use the next
election whenever it comes as um the
former leader had suggested Nicola
sturgeon as a referendum for
Independence I think what he will do
over the coming period he'll set out
isto he wants to make sure that he
reaches out to people in the SNP in The
Wider YES Movement but of course
crucially right across Scotland no
voters undecided voters let's make sure
we have that debate about what kind of
country the debate to a large extent has
been focused on processed and that's
important there is a mandate for an
independence referendum that the
parliament has has been granted by the
people of Scotland but crucially it'll
be about how we change Scotland for the
better and I hope as a consequence of
that driving our support for
Independence in the end this will happen
crucially not by the um Parliament at
Westminster or indeed the Supreme Court
well but at the end of the day who has
the right to choose Scotland's future
it's the Supreme Court well at the well
at the moment what has happened of
course is Richie sunac is not respecting
that there is an independence majority
in the parliament we will lead the
independence movement he will do that
and we will seek to build support for
Independence in the and Westminster
can't continue to say no if the people
in Scotland saying yes they want to say
in their future Michael go over the
leveling up secretary said he couldn't
think of a singles thing to praise of
Nicholas sturgeon during her time in
office when he was asked at the weekend
my goodness that's rather remarkable
isn't it for Michael and I'm
disappointed in him the end of the day
nickel Sergeant has led us through eight
years and I think crucially give
fantastic leadership in particular
through the covert pandemic I think
everyone will remember Nicola coming
into our living rooms through Sky
Television I think to give really first
class communication real leadership real
guidance right through that crisis I'm
grateful for the way that she has led us
over that what do you think she'll do
next you think she's done with policy
she says she's going to take some time
to learn to drive she's still a
relatively young woman so I think she's
got an awful lot to give let's wait and
see she's not going to walk away from
the SNP or the independence movement
she'll be a good supporter of the
Scottish government of Hamza Yusuf but
no doubt that her noted talents she is a
fantastic Communicator I think we'll see
enough a lot more of Nicholas dungeon
yet okay good to see you thanks very
much indeed for joining us as always
thank you